Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Conner's again talking about nodule two in this stop fighting cancer course
In this module, I'm going to give you a brief overview of our Conner's method and
understand
There's a lot of information in this. I'm really shriking it down
Please make sure you download a free copy of my stop fighting cancer and start reading the cause book because that can be a
Wealth of information for you as well
Plus I have several other books that you'll want to download and
Look at as you go through these modules just to remind her for you the detoxification book
We extremely helpful when you start getting into some of the our
Methods are our pillars that we're talking about here
And then dealing with that spiritual side
And that emotional side is such a key what you're dealing with a serious disease. You don't want to ignore that
So let's go over what I have labeled a
Number of years ago when I first started treating cancer back in the late 1990s
Boy, that seems like a long time ago
And the early 2000s that came up with what I called the four pillars
Now there's there's a lot in each one of these pillars
So we could expand it to be the 24 pillars, but I'm trying to keep this simple in
Understanding these pieces because I do believe that when you're dealing with a serious disease
You already got enough going through your head
That you don't need to be confused. We got to keep this simple
So and our approach is simple and some people have complained that it's too simple, but
If you don't keep it simple, people don't stay on things and people don't stick with things
And then well, what good is that then they don't have results at all?
So you have to keep it simple and easy to do and
As least disruptive in a person's lifestyle
Or no matter how motivated you are to start we're gonna juice 12 glasses of juice a day
And we're gonna you know go on a complete ketogenic diet and we're gonna do all this stuff
It becomes so life disrupting that that isn't good for us in a lot of ways
It become we could actually make an idol on a treating our cancer or our disease and then that becomes very spiritual
A big spiritual issue or we could make it so complicated that we can't stick
with it and we can have that motivation for a period of time and then it
Weeds and wades quickly and after a couple weeks
We're so exhausted from trying to treat treat our cancer treat our disease that
We're sick from that and you know dealing with myself personally and dealing with patients
You know back as the last 27 years
It's the easier that you can make it in the least life
Disrupting that you can make it the better results we get which seems kind of ironic shouldn't we be taking
47 different bottles of supplements at three of them three times a day makes you
150 supplements a day that have to follow this diet and do all these procedures and go to these clinics and get IVs and do all this
In order to get better because I'm really sick. Well
There's truth that we do need to do some things there is a work on our part if we're going to get better from being sick
We do have to change lifestyle things
But the least disruptive you can make it the better it's going to be because you'll stick to it
It doesn't have to be a grandiose change to make a big difference and
That's the key. It doesn't have to be a grandiose change
To make a big difference
A lot of people especially men are really happy to hear that
Because men got a lot of things on their mind already not that women don't but they tend to be
less focused on their body and you know being able to stick to a diet
Maybe it's just our makeup. I don't know what it is women tend to be much better disciplined at those things
But we want to keep this a very doable procedure so it's we go through these four pillars
I'm going to give an overview in this module and then in the following modules
We're going to dig deep into each one of these things our first pillar is to address the cause
We talked about that already my book is titled that stop fighting cancer and start treating the cause
And I titled it that way because that was my philosophy from the very beginning
With my first cancer patient. We're not going to have this fight
I don't think that's healthy if we're fighting something in our body and I understand I've seen these these you know
blank cancer bumper stickers up the out there and
People could get very emotional when they're dealing with a serious disease that could kill them and they can get angry and they can become bitter
Or they can they can have these emotions and I and I realized that could be healthy to go through those
But we have to go through them
We have to come out at the other end and take a more pregnant
Pregmatic position in that okay now. What am I going to do about this?
Fighting and being angry at our cancer. I don't think solves the problem
I think we need to take a step back and look at it
There are causes to cancer
Remember cancer is something got inside of a cell one cell and
Interrupted the cellular
replication in the nucleus of that cell and now that cell is
Replicating uncontrollably
Divided and divided and divided replicated at a much greater rate than what is normal?
Normally most cells will divide will replicate and then the mother cells
Eventually die off through a process called apoptosis normal program cell death, which is basically a recycling of that cell matter to be used
throughout the body
But when that doesn't happen and a cell goes into rapid replication mode
Because of something that got inside of that cell
Then we're in trouble. So we do want to address that cause what wasn't that got inside that cell was it a
Was it a biotoxid was it a virus was it a bacteria was it a pesticide an herbicide?
What is tied to that also the pieces of cause is it driven by hormones is it driven by a
Bad environment. We want to address those pieces. It's funny that medicine is very good at looking at causes
Of cancer when they do all these studies on well, this causes cancer this causes cancer and you you know hardly a week goes by without
You see another cause of cancer, but then how come when somebody gets cancer?
That is never addressed never have I had anybody come to me that says hey, I found out I have cancer and it's because of a pesticide
They don't they don't look for that even though hey
Pesticides are probably the number one cause of lymphomas and leukebias, but never had a lymphoma patient come and tell me that
So we want to look for that. There's a ways to test for that and we'll talk about that in the next module actually
And then we want to address the cancer itself. That's that's pillar number two. We do need to find a
Nutri-suitical from our perspective an herbal or a homeopathic
Protocol that's going to be best suited for that person's body to stimulate the immune system to kill the cancer
We want to address the cancer not just taking care of the cause, but we have to address the cancer
And we have to do it in a way that we're not using a ton of stuff in the least amount of things possible again
Keeping it simple keeping it doable keeping it that you can continue to do this on a regular basis when the motivation starts to wane and
Then we want to use technology. We use rife technology. We use pf technology. We use hyperthermia hyperbaric
There's technology out there that can help the body
Immune system attack the cancer to be rife technology is the best as far as getting the body to focus on that cancer
Part of the reason why your immune system
Doesn't kill a cancer is that the cancer cell is still self-tissue
It's still your own cells and your immune system is programmed to not kill self-tissue
So you've got to get the immune system the T cells the macrophages the natural killer cells to be able to attack that
Cancer that's growing out of control that rapid replication of cells and you do that with hitting it with its own frequencies
You're causing it to vibrate you're causing the immune system to refocus on that and look at that again
Oh my gosh, what is that maybe we need to take a second look?
Maybe we need to kill that rapidly growing mass so we do rife programming specific to that cancer so that person's body can
Best help kill the cancer and personally I believe using rife helps immune products neuters
Suticals and things help target the cancer and even
chemotherapy and immunotherapy it helps the target the cancer so that's my personal opinion
I have no research to prove that
But we've seen that in our practice
So I think rife is invaluable. I don't think I'd be standing here talking to you right now if I didn't use a rife machine
So I think a rife machine isn't valuable and you need one that's going to be able to penetrate the body
It'd be easiest to use and we'll go into that in detail in coming modules as well
And then lastly you need to clean up the terrain
We talked about this in the last module gave a really neat picture of a fish and a dirty take and a fish and a clean take
Real easy picture to understand that your terrain your environment is super important
That environment to where that cancer is growing
Needs to be cleaned. That's the process detoxification. That's a process of just natural healing
Lots of talk about
pH balance, but cancer is growing in a rapid state
Causing an acidic environment at that cancer. So we need to detoxify detoxify and clean that area out
so
Those are the four pillars that we're going to dive into in these modules stick with me here
Download my book as I said download my detoxification book and
My cancer can't kill you if you're already dead book start dealing with the emotional spiritual side start dealing with
With the detox understanding detoxification of the seven phases of detoxification and how important that is
Those things you start doing these things no matter if you're choosing standards of care
Along with this or not will help you tremendously
All right, I just pray that this is a blessing to all of you and we'll see you at the next module